comment ça va aujourd'hui j'espère que
vous allez bien le reviens se comparer
des smartphones au niveau de la photo on
a ici bien évidemment le Samsung Galaxy
S23 ultra le chien omi 13 pro et
l'iPhone 14 pro max on se fait ça à
Barcelone dans des conditions presque
qui déliques c'est pas tout à fait le
printemps mais presque en tout cas ça
commence à y ressembler et puis je
compte sur vous mais évidemment pour me
dire qu'est-ce que vous préférez
qu'est-ce que vous aimez qu'est-ce que
vous aimez pas en bateau regarder le
mode portrait on va regarder les photos
de jour les photos de nuit les
téléobjectif les ultra grand temps les
caméras de selfie et puis un peu de
vidéo tout de suite avec nos côtés votre
Samsung votre Xiaomi votre iPhone est-ce
que vous êtes prêts moi je suis prêt
allez on y va
c'est aujourd'hui une vidéo qui est
réalisée en partenariat avec cyberGhost
VPN pourquoi parce que c'est extrêmement
important de venir protéger votre
sécurité en ligne oui je vais vous
expliquer alors en VPN c'est quoi un VPN
ça vient protéger votre sécurité en
ligne mais également votre
confidentialité être qui est cool c'est
que si cyberGhost a plus de 15 ans
d'expérience dans ce domaine là donc ça
c'est extrêmement rassurant et il compte
plus de 38 millions d'utilisateurs à
travers le monde je donne un exemple ici
on est à Barcelone dans le cadre dans
salon et j'utilise justement mon VPN
pour venir protéger ma connexion dans
mon hôtel je me connecte directement au
wifi l'hôtel mais si une personne mal
intentionnée veut venir intercepter mes
données elle peut venir le faire elle
peut venir récupérer ma connexion et ça
c'est pas bien du tout et qu'est-ce
qu'on vient faire mon VPN et bien
justement il vient apporter une couche
de sécurité là dessus il vient crypter
mes données il vient anonymiser mon
contenu il vient manonymiser comme ça
personne peut venir récupérer mes
données et ça c'est bien il vient donc
chiffrer mon trafic en ligne masquer mon
adresse IP et redirige tout mon trafic
Internet au travers d'un tunnel crypté
comme ça les hackers les annonceurs à
tous ceux qui veulent récupérer de la
data et bien ils peuvent pas et ça tant
mieux mais ça permet autre chose ça
permet de débloquer du contenu auquel
vous n'auriez pas accès à cause de la
géolocalisation par exemple si vous
voulez regarder du contenu sur des
plateformes vidéo Netflix Amazon Prime
vidéo Disney plus du contenu disponible
par exemple uniquement aux États-Unis et
bien grâce à votre VPN vous vous
connectez sur un serveur aux États-Unis
et vous allez pouvoir bénéficier de ce
contenu en avant-première et ça c'est
chouette mais ça va également aller dans
votre sens lorsque vous allez venir
faire des achats en ligne et notamment
consulter vos comptes bancaires avec
cyberGhost VPN pour connecter jusqu'à
cet appareil à partir d'un seul et même
abonnement que ce soit sur Windows MacOS
Android iOS Linux vous pouvez le
configurer sur un routeur une Smart TV
un Amazon fire TV stick ou encore une
console de jeux donc ça c'est vachement
bien il conserve zéro données vous
concernant ils ont une politique zérolog
il ne vous suivent pas ne partage pas et
ne revend pas vos données ils viennent
crypter votre trafic avec un chiffre
mort de pointe AES 256 bits et il masque
bien évidemment votre localisation ils
ont beaucoup de serveurs dans le monde
entier Amérique Europe Asie Afrique bref
un peu partout dans le monde savait Pen
qui est très rapide pour streamer
téléchargez des fichiers volumineux
jouer à des jeux bref extrêmement
complet en plus de ça il y a une
garantie satisfait ou remboursé pendant
45 jours une assistance 24/24 7 jours
sur 7 par mail et par chat et bien
évidemment dans plusieurs langues
cyberGhost VPN est extrêmement simple à
venir installer à venir utiliser il y a
pas besoin de connaissances
particulières allez jeter un coup d'œil
sur le site de cyberGhost il y a des
tarifs extrêmement intéressants qui vous
permet d'avoir une sécurité en ligne à
un tarif mini mini mini profitez d'une
réduction de - 82 %. pensez donc à venir
vous protéger grâce à cyberGhost GPN une
fois de plus je vous mets le lien juste
en bas dans la description et merci à
cyberGhost d'avoir sponsorisé cette
vidéo
me voilà de retour au studio les photos
sont là et on a bien évidemment les
trois smartphones donc on se compare
aujourd'hui le Samsung Galaxy S23 ultra
qui est un excellent photophone que
j'adore ils ont vraiment super bien
bossé là-dessus Samsung cette année on a
également le chien omis de 13 pro
premier smartphone en partenaire pas
premier smartphone grand public lancés
réellement en partenariat avec Leica en
tout cas en France et qui est très cool
on l'a déjà vu sur ma chaîne youtube et
puis on va aller avec je dirais des
références l'iPhone 14 pro Max qui est
juste là qui est aussi un excellent
smartphone un excellent photophone on a
fait il y a pas longtemps un comparatif
avec l'iPhone 14 pro max avec le Samsung
Galaxy S23 ultra et on avait le Google
le pixel 7 Pro qui était là là je vous
voulais pas complexifier un peu plus et
rajouter le pixel donc on se compare
vraiment ça aujourd'hui on utilise un
iPhone 14 pro Max comme une référence
parce que ça reste quand même une vraie
référence les iPhone le Galaxy S23 j'ai
vraiment choisi de le mettre parce que
c'est vraiment un smartphone que j'adore
et je trouve que Samsung a vraiment mais
vraiment vraiment bien bossé ils sont
montés d'un cran par rapport à ce qu'on
avait l'année dernière et puis surtout
on vient vraiment mettre en perspective
ce Xiaomi 13 pro pourquoi parce que
c'est la première fois avec les cartes
c'est surtout là-dessus qu'on vient se
concentrer alors on y va regarder on y
va on se plonge directement donc on a
trois photos qu'est-ce que je suis venu
faire j'ai venu prendre des photos de
nuit des photos de jour du mode portrait
on est venu regarder ces points qui sont
les points essentiels et on est venu
regarder le grand angle l'ultra
grand-angle le téléobjectif on va
jusqu'au bout du bout du bout du bout
jusque là où on peut aller en tout cas
alors la première chose à venir regarder
vous avez ici là sur la gauche et bien
c'est le Samsung Galaxy S23
ultra qui est magnifique on est au
milieu le Xiaomi 13 pro et qu'on a à
droite l'iPhone 14 pro première chose à
voir on est dans un institut à Barcelone
regardez alors là il y a un truc qui est
très très fort et très significatif dès
le départ il y a alors vous allez voir
il y a plein de choses on est vraiment
sur le plus haut de gamme donc si vous
voulez on est vraiment sur regarder du
point de détail parce que les
smartphones sont vraiment excellents
excellents excellent en photo mais celle
que j'ai vraiment bien préféré dès le
départ ici avec cette couleur qui est un
peu particulière et bien c'est le Galaxy
S23 ultra pourquoi et bien parce que je
trouve que il est beaucoup plus juste on
a du détail la colorimétrie est juste
par rapport à ce que j'ai vu c'est
vraiment ça sauf que Xiaomi s'en sort
pas des masses la couleur est vraiment
très très différente et j'aime pas des
masses alors je vous le dis j'ai fait le
choix de prendre toutes les photos ici
avec le Xiaomi on est en Leica
authentique donc on sera moins saturé
que ce qu'on va venir retrouver
notamment au niveau du smartphone de
Samsung qui lui va saturer davantage et
puis vous avez ici la copie de l'iPhone
que je trouve moins bonne clairement
celui que j'ai préféré qui est plus
neutre qui est le plus jolie et qui est
le plus proche de la réalité ici c'est
Samsung je vous emmène ensuite avec un
petit coucher de soleil la lumière
commence à laisser on a de très jolies
couleurs dans le ciel là c'est une fois
de plus sur un truc qui est vraiment
intéressant c'est à dire que si vous
regardez Samsung et si vous regardez
Xiaomi c'est assez proche au niveau de
la colorimétrie une fois de plus on a
les cas authentique donc un peu moins
saturé par contre chez Apple le
traitement est vraiment différent on est
plus sur le rose et Samsung on est plus
sur le oranger un peu feu chez Apple ce
qu'il faut venir regarder c'est
effectivement cette couleur du ciel et
puis bien évidemment les bâtiments les
lumières comment est-ce que ça réagit
dans l'ensemble on est sur de l'ultra
haut de gamme donc ça marche très bien
et ça réagit très bien tous les côtés
mais en terme de sensibilité purement
artistique ce que je viens préférer ici
ce sont les couleurs qui sont plus
proches de la réalité comme j'ai plus le
voir vraiment de mes propres yeux j'ai
moins le rendu ici de l'iPhone et si
j'ai le choix entre les deux au-delà de
la colorimétrie je trouve que les deux
sont vraiment bien que ce soit Xiaomi
d'un côté que ce soit Samsung à côté de
l'autre difficile de venir les
départager ici je regarde au niveau des
zones d'ombre également je peux les deux
vraiment sont très très bons ici donc
bon c'est un peu ex aequo on continue
avec des couleurs à l'intérieur c'est le
soir également alors ça c'est assez
intéressant pourquoi parce que en fait
je vais venir trouver que c'est l'iPhone
qui s'en sort le mieux et je vais vous
dire sur quoi je me base alors on peut
venir regarder un peu tout dans la photo
on peut regarder le fond la voyez le
fond il est un peu moins nette du côté
de chez Xiaomi bon l'iPhone ça
fonctionne le Samsung s'en sort
merveilleusement bien mais le truc que
je vais vraiment venir sur tout regarder
c'est ce petit détail là sur la nappe
regardez sur l'iPhone vous avez vraiment
le détail on le voit bien c'est clair
c'est beau c'est bien fait c'est Samsung
c'est aussi plutôt pas mal fichu alors
je trouve que ici il s'en sort beaucoup
moins bien chez Xiaomi on le voit
beaucoup moins regardez un vrai grosse
différence entre Apple et entre Xiaomi
et d'une manière générale alors c'est je
trouve ça un peu plus neutre le rendu
qu'on a ici au niveau des couleurs que
ce qu'on a ici qui est un peu plus terne
aussi sur le smartphone de Xiaomi et
chez Samsung bon voilà sur cette
photo-là ça m'emporte un petit peu moins
par contre le truc que je trouve pas mal
ici c'est que je trouve que
l'arrière-plan était un peu plus nette
donc le point dû être fait davantage par
ici vous voyez que là le point est plus
là là c'est un peu plus flou donc le
point vraiment plus cet effet derrière
ce qui peut aussi expliquer la
différence on continue notre petite
balade le soir on est à Barcelone ici on
a toujours ces trois photos alors ce qui
est très très intéressant à venir
regarder c'est la façon qui va venir se
comporter entre les lumières plus fortes
des lumières plus sombres notamment ici
au niveau de la colonne et alors moi le
truc qui m'intéresse vous voyez quand je
vois des colonnes comme ça c'est la pire
j'ai envie de pouvoir la regarder
d'après pour pouvoir ressentir la
matière qu'elle soit vraiment bien
restituée et je trouve qu'elle est très
très bien restituer notamment sur cette
colonne là ici chez Apple je trouve
qu'elle est un peu moins chez X la
matière sera un peu moins présente elle
est pas mal aussi ici du côté de Samsung
mais elle est moins bien présente c'est
assez subtil mais je trouve ça quand
même beaucoup mieux ici du côté de chez
Apple pour autant ça fonctionne plutôt
bien regardons les lumières au fond
voyez c'est très bien maîtrisé d'un côté
et de l'autre peut-être un petit poil
différent du côté de chez Xiaomi mais
ici c'est vraiment du point de détail on
continue notre balade une fois de plus
on est regardé la matière voyez la
matière que j'aime vraiment retrouver
ici chez Xiaomi elle disparaît
réellement et ici je l'ai mais un petit
peu moins donc je vais préférer je pense
le rendu de l'iPhone je vais le trouver
meilleur par rapport à ce que je vais
retrouver chez Xiaomi et chez Samsung
soit assez proche par contre je trouve
tous les deux au niveau du rendu final
c'est un peu plus écrasé du côté de de
l'iPhone mais globalement on a plus la
matière donc on est plus proche de la
réalité donc ça me plais davantage
maintenant on va sur une question très
intéressante c'est la question de la
macro pourquoi parce qu'on fait pas du
tout écrou de la même manière si vous
êtes chez Samsung et si vous êtes chez
Apple on va utiliser l'ultra grand-angle
pour venir faire de la macro tandis que
chez Xiaomi on va utiliser le
téléobjectif on va venir zoomer en gros
dans l'image et ça se voit réellement
qu'il y a une vraie grosse différence
moi je vais préférer ici vous allez voir
le rendu de Samsung parce que je trouve
que on voit bien tous les poils vous
voyez tous les détails qu'on vient
retrouver ici au niveau de la fleur on
pourrait presque ressentir cette petite
pilosité de je sais pas qu'on appelle ça
réellement au niveau d'une planche j'en
suis désolé mais on va le ressentir
davantage je vais le ressentir un peu
effectivement sur sur l'iPhone mais
beaucoup moins ici sur le Xiaomi 13 pro
et je trouve ça dommage et je vais me
balader je fais différentes photos et je
trouve que une fois de plus on a
beaucoup moins cet effet matière qu'on
vient retrouver davantage voyez on a
bien la matière ici et sur l'iPhone je
trouve que on le retrouve quand même un
petit peu moins là un peu plus sur cette
photo là mais c'est moins évident vous
voyez alors c'est très joli attention on
est vraiment en train de comparer des
smartphones ultra haut de gamme donc on
est vraiment sur du point de détail mais
celui qui s'en sort le moins bien ici et
bien je trouve ça va vraiment être le
Xiaomi 13 pro tandis que l'iPhone tanti
que le Samsung Galaxy S23 ultra
sortiront beaucoup mieux l'appareil on
continue avec toujours
le même ordre et bien je trouve que
celui qui s'en sortirait le mieux c'est
une fois de plus le Galaxy S23 ultra
plus de détails plus juste plus beau bon
après j'essaye différents trucs mais
celui qui me plaira et qui m'emmènera
davantage une fois de plus et bien ça va
être le Galaxy S23 ultra parce que là la
gestion de la lumière elle se trouve un
peu moins bonne on le voit un peu moins
alors je passais du pistil par un grand
spécialiste de la plante qu'ici c'est
plus équilibré et ça me plaira davantage
alors c'est pas mauvais au niveau des
rendus de la colorimétrie effectivement
sur le Xiaomi mais ça m'emmène quand
même moins moins dans l'histoire on
continue ici regardez on a bien la
matière on la voit on la voit bien les
poils la matière ici chez Samsung on l'a
chez Xiaomi mais beaucoup moins c'est
beaucoup moins joli surtout c'est un peu
plus loin je suis pas forcément fan du
choix qu'ils ont fait ça marche pas trop
trop mal attention on va comparer c'est
qu'on parle ça marche pas trop mal chez
Apple mais ici pour moi le leader la
macro c'est vraiment incontestablement
le Samsung allez encore quelques petites
photos ici à venir regarder on a bien la
matière de tous les côtés c'est
magnifique je suis mise en sorte pas
trop trop mal mais dans l'ensemble c'est
quand même pas le roi de la macro hein
soyons clair regardez-moi ça là
franchement ça n'a rien à voir on
continue notre balade dans bar regarde
un peu les toits c'est joli c'est sympa
j'aime Barcelone j'adore cette vie
d'ailleurs je sais pas si c'est votre
cas parce que moi dans les commentaires
c'est une ville où j'aurais vraiment
vraiment pu vivre alors une fois de plus
là si vous le prenez comme ça
globalement ça raconte à peu près la
même histoire petite différence au
niveau du traitement du ciel mais c'est
très très très léger dans tous les cas
c'est beau ça marche bien pas vraiment
voir de réels différents ici on passe
sur l'ultra grand-angle on regarde sur
toute traitement au niveau du ciel qui
va bien tout est clair le soleil là ok
ça marche bien un peu plus terne très
légèrement ici au niveau du traitement
au niveau des façades qui sont là contre
jour mais très très légèrement celui qui
sera un peu plus clair ici ça va être le
Samsung Galaxy S23 ultra mais c'est
vraiment du point de détail on vient
ensuite se rapprocher vous voyez on sort
un petit peu mieux ça me saoule Apple
pas mal et Xiaomi un peu derrière une
fois de plus on compare vraiment sur du
ultra haut de gamme donc bon il faut y
aller avec avec parcimonie au niveau de
la critique là-dessus bon ça fonctionne
on vient se rapprocher et vous allez
voir que de toute façon au niveau du
zoom celui qui sera le meilleur ça va
être Samsung avec son space zoom c'est
là où on va aller le plus loin vous
voyez on commence à perdre déjà un petit
peu au niveau du détail ici tandis que
Samsung si vous regardez là ça sent
vachement bien Apple est pas trop trop
mauvais mais plus difficile utile et dès
qu'on vient zoomer zoomer forcément
zoomer davantage vous voyez on a déjà
perdu Apple Xiaomi il a déjà c'est pas
terrible terrible vous venez vous
rapprocher on va vraiment la grosse
grosse différence faut dire vous avez
deux téléobjectif vous avez un X3
optique un fournisseur optique donc
forcément on va aller beaucoup plus loin
c'est normal il est quand même beaucoup
plus équipé regardez le détail ici bon
c'est normal rien de bien sûr prenant
ici là on continue notre petite balade
je trouve que ça me saoule s'en sort
aussi mieux c'est légèrement légèrement
légèrement un peu plus foncé très léger
au niveau de la façade du bâtiment
Xiaomi versus Samsung une fois de plus
il y a le filtre Leica authentique donc
bon c'est ça qui joue un peu sur
l'histoire l'ultra grand-angle ça
fonctionne les trois globalement se
tiennent elles sont quand même très très
bon là-dessus il y a vraiment pas grand
chose à venir redire et lorsqu'on vient
zoomer forcément et bien c'est là où ça
me saoule s'en sortira le mieux on va
déjà au niveau du détail ici parce qu'on
vient se rapprocher une fois de plus ça
ne tourne ça sort mieux on peut
commencer avancer on va dire qu'on a
perdu là c'est beaucoup moins bon au
niveau de Xiaomi mais une fois de plus
on a le double téléobjectif du côté de
chez Samsung donc c'est normal donc
lorsque vous venez zoomer davantage et
bien arrive un moment où les autres bah
ils peuvent plus en faire vous voyez
globalement là il y a une vraie grosse
différence mais bon quoi c'est pas bien
sûr prenant on continue avec la Sagrada
Familia vous allez voir c'est super
intéressant alors si vous la regardez
comme ça globalement ça fonctionne les 3
sont très bons il y a absolument rien à
dire ça marche bien il y a des petites
différences qui sont faites au niveau de
la colo c'est le choix du fabricant mais
ça va très très bien les grands angles
les ultra grand-angle de phases
globalement ça va bien ça déforme pas
c'est clair c'est bossé net on vient
ensuite se rapprocher les trois sont
bons et de la même manière que ce que je
vous ai montré sur les autres celui qui
sera le bien meilleur et bien fatalement
ça va être le Galaxy S23 ultra même si
l'iPhone regarder quand même vachement
bien à ce point de détail je trouve que
là vous avez le Galaxy S23 ultra qui au
dessus vous avez ensuite iPhone 14 pro
max c'est quand même très très bien et
tout de suite le Xiaomi sera un peu
moins bon le téléobjectif de Xiaomi est
pas très très bon et je trouve que c'est
vraiment la grosse différence qu'on va
venir retrouver ici vous voyez il y a un
moment ça tire un petit peu sur la
couane et c'est quand même vachement moi
qualitatif après pour autant est-ce
qu'il y a un intérêt à venir zoomer
autant je ne suis pas convaincu en même
temps d'un contre je raconte autre chose
aussi super intéressant au-delà de la
différence de colorimétrie mais si vous
regardez là on a bien tous les détails
au niveau de la grue qui est à
contre-jour en pas dans le soleil on l'a
davantage sur le côté de Samsung donc
chez xomi ça sent très très bien Apple
on sort aussi très très bien la
différence qu'on a ici fait ce petit
rayon qui vient de votre optique de
votre lentille c'est le Lens bon il y a
rien de bien surprenant lorsque vous
venez prendre un contre jour différence
de coloris maîtris une fois de plus mais
bon c'est pas anormal et dans tous les
cas ça fonctionne bien on aime bien la
façade de tous les côtés du bâtiment
c'est juste magnifique j'adore la
Sagrada Familia et lorsque vous passez
sur l'ultra grand-angle il y a une vraie
différence regardez c'est vraiment
intéressant alors au lieu de la colo une
fois de plus parce qu'on est sur le Ikea
authentique ici le soleil est mieux
gérer ce contre jour ici au niveau de
l'ultra grand-angle sur le Samsung
Galaxy S23 ultra il n'est pas trop trop
mal géré sur le Xiaomi est très pro
alors ça l'iPhone a tout de suite
beaucoup plus de mal hop là j'ai perdu
une lumière bleue par là au revoir
lumière à bientôt il est un peu plus de
mal donc voyez c'est un peu la limite du
truc mais après pour autant le bâtiment
est là tout est plutôt bien fait bien
maîtrisé globalement ça fonctionne donc
c'est une fois de plus du point de
détail on va regarder si au niveau du
verre et bien les Verts sont beaux sont
bien maîtrisés je vais préférer le
détail que j'ai retrouvé ici du côté de
Samsung et de l'iPhone un peu moins de
chez Xiaomi bon c'est vraiment vraiment
du point de détail alors là il y a un
autre truc qui est super intéressant ici
à venir regarder c'est parce que vous
avez tous pas le choix de couleur vous
allez vraiment venir regarder par
exemple là chez Samsung je vais trouver
que c'est pas mauvais là un petit bonbon
là cette espèce de banane je trouve bien
je les trouve bien cramé ici du côté de
chez Xiaomi donc la gestion de la haute
lumière là elle est pas très très bonne
et là alors l'iPhone est pas mal parce
qu'une fois de plus comme on a vu tout à
l'heure dans le noir il nous restitue
bien les matières donc là on a vraiment
le maintien le côté un petit peu le
sucre au-dessus du bonbon ça donne
beaucoup plus envie si je vais regarder
vous voyez la espèce de petite fraise de
côté bon c'est pas mal ça donne envie
pas de sucre là il y a à côté d'un peu
moins net tout simplement la netteté ici
et du côté de chez Samsung un petit peu
moins donc on a tout de suite ce côté
avec un peu plus de de piqué de détails
en tout cas qu'on vient retrouver du
côté de chez l'iPhone que je trouve pas
le mal du côté de chez l'iPhone du côté
de l'iPhone mec je ne sais plus parler
français on le retrouve également ici un
peu moins ici et là c'est pas très très
bon il est plus aux fraises je vais
vraiment ce qu'il y a de bien dire je
suis sur les fraises il est davantage
aux fraises donc ici avantage très
clairement lié à l'iPhone on va regarder
la caméra de selfie avec caméra de
selfie aussi un sujet super intéressant
je suis pas trop emballé ici par Xiaomi
regardez la façade la comme elle est
blanche et cramée ici je trouve que
l'iPhone s'en sort vraiment bien c'est
très équilibré ça marche bien coucou
Anne qui est derrière sur toutes les
photos même ici sur le Galaxy S23
ultra et bien pareil la façade est très
bien maîtrisée ça marche bien mais j'ai
préféré la couleur qu'on vient retrouver
ici du côté de une fois de plus un grain
de peau qui est meilleur une plus jolie
qualité au niveau de la caméra de selfie
alors là je me mets à contre-jour ils
s'en sortent quand même plutôt pas trop
mal mais celui qui est vraiment le
meilleur c'est une fois de plus l'iPhone
ici je trouve que c'est un peu trop au
lycée c'est un peu moins joli il y a
moins de piquer du côté du Xiaomi c'est
pas ouf le Galaxy S23 s'en sort pas mal
mais bon je préfère quand même l'iPhone
ici de la même manière ici l'iPhone
tente de poids un peu plus sur le violet
ici un peu plus sur le verre du côté du
Galaxy et je trouve ça moins beau moins
précis au niveau de Xiaomi vous voyez
même sur la tête de Léo là il est un peu
plus vert et là il est un peu plus sur
le violet donc voyez ça c'est une
question de curseur où est-ce qu'on la
met et bien je trouve que c'est un peu
meilleur ici même au niveau de la
matière derrière du bâtiment que ce que
j'ai là qui est tout de suite beaucoup
plus vert et je trouve ça pas terrible
alors le mode portrait c'est un mode qui
est plus compliqué pourquoi parce qu'en
fait Xiaomi avec son partenariat avec
Leica va vraiment venir travailler
différemment il y a des filtres dès que
vous êtes sur le portrait de base vous
êtes en noir et blanc ils veulent
retrouver un peu le côté Leica il y a de
la douceur il y a ce petit grain qu'on
va retrouver au niveau des Noirs qui est
très joli donc c'est peut-être un peu
plus compliqué de venir le comparer
comme ça ici globalement je trouve que
il s'en sort bien tous les trois la
philosophie est un peu différente le
détourage est très bon de tous les côtés
c'est très coup je trouve que du côté de
chez Xiaomi raconte une autre histoire
avec les cannes et qui est très très
belle également alors lorsque vous venez
zoomer vous vous rapprocher car vous
allez sur un autre mode en fait au
niveau de votre mode portrait et bien
vous allez voir que vous avez différents
filtres là le premier ça va être en noir
et blanc c'est 35 mm le deuxième c'est
un 50 c'est le squiriboké le troisième
c'est du portrait en 75 et puis vous
avez le flow artistique en 90 mm vous
allez voir parce que le flow artistique
en 90 mm je le trouve pas bon du tout
donc vous voyez vous venez vous
rapprocher là là OK et dès que vous avez
sur le 90 mm non de Dieu qu'est-ce que
c'est que ce flou artistique dégueulasse
j'aime pas du tout donc après si vous
venez regarder wall là c'est quoi cette
tronche du côté de chez Samsung ou du
côté de l'iPhone et bien quand je ouvre
les yeux et que je fais pas trop la
gueule ça fait pas trop le cas là ça
marche bien écoute un peu plus lissé au
niveau du visage sur le Galaxy un peu
moins sur l'iPhone bon l'iPhone s'en
sort quand même vachement bien regardez
là c'est pareil de la même manière ici
c'est pas du tout le même cadre en fait
c'est pas du tout le même choix qui est
fait donc c'est compliqué de venir les
mettre à face à face mais si vous
regardez dites ce que vous aimez ce que
vous préférez entre ces trois versions
vous voyez c'est vraiment pas le même
rendu je trouve qu'il y a donc au niveau
de la lumière au niveau de la netteté
qui est moins lâche et chez Samsung je
vais moins aimé j'aime pas trop ce qu'il
y a ce côté contraste un peu
différemment après c'est de la photo
hein donc je suis un peu moins fan je
préfère peut-être que nous propose ici
quand même Apple au niveau de son mode
portrait même si il y a un truc chez
Xiaomi qui est quand même relativement
intéressant une fois de plus avec le
laiton en noir et blanc regardez là ici
on vient comparer bon globalement ça
marche bien on aura un côté un peu plus
contraste un peu plus de matière très
léger ici du côté de l'iPhone un peu
moins sur les deux autres mais les
couleurs sont jolies je préfère
peut-être la couleur des chaises au
niveau de l'iPhone regardez lorsque vous
venez vous rapprocher vous venez zoomer
ça reste à peu près équivalent mais ça
reste très joli dans tous les cas donc
on peut pas grand chose à venir raconter
ici c'est mode portrait une fois de plus
hop là on continue à se balader bon
voilà c'est une fois de plus c'est pas
qu'elle vous intéresse le plus quel vous
plaît le plus au niveau du mode portrait
dites-le-moi d'ailleurs dans les
commentaires un peu de bouffe pour ceux
qui aiment les barbecues coréen et bien
je trouve que celui qui s'en sort le
mieux ici ça va être une fois de plus le
Galaxy S23 ultra au niveau du détail
c'est très joli j'aime pas trop le rendu
qu'on a ici du côté de Xiaomi ça c'est
un peu sur ma faim que de le dire sans
mauvais jeu de mots du côté de l'iPhone
c'est pas mauvais c'est globalement pas
mauvais mais voilà c'est pas tout à fait
la même philosophie on se fait un petit
tour la nuit du côté de Barcelone le
Xiaomi 13 pro on va avoir le bâtiment
qui sera un peu plus foncé derrière on
le verra un peu mieux il sera un peu
mieux exposé sortira mieux en tout cas
au niveau du traitement et du côté du
Galaxy S23 ultra l'iPhone ça aussi un
petit peu foncé mais globalement une
fois de plus on est vraiment en train de
comparer de points de détails ce que je
vais bien aimé c'est une fois de plus
plus de détails ici plus de matière au
niveau de l'iPhone donc si vous aimez la
matière si vous aimez que les choses
ressortent et qui est un peu plus de
piqué on va aller ici du côté de
l'iPhone très clairement après il y a un
côté beaucoup plus saturé chez Samsung
ça s'est toujours un petit peu le cas
mais on peut dire que franchement le
Xiaomi 13 pour s'en sort aussi vraiment
très très bien on continue un peu de la
façade la nuit voyez c'est très joli
bien fait bien maîtrisé on a bien le
détail en haut si on sent vraiment très
bien tous les trois honnêtement c'est
compliqué de venir le dire lequel est le
meilleur au niveau de la gestion de
votre lumière on voit que l'iPhone a eu
beaucoup plus de mal et à cramé
davantage ici tandis que Xiaomi tu l'as
bien préservé et que le Samsung a encore
mieux préservé une façade également ici
d'une boutique la nuit c'est bien
maîtrisé d'un côté et de l'autre ça
marche bien de tous les côtés une fois
de plus ça c'est très compliqué vu dans
les départager là-dessus on continue
chez Gaudi en Espagne à Barcelone
toujours une fois de plus les trois sont
très très bons bien maîtriser la lumière
ok ça fonctionne bien le détail bien le
roi du détail le roi de la matière ça va
être l'iPhone j'aime bien les petits
jeux donc qui ressortent davantage ici
chez Samsung et Xiaomi s'en sort
globalement aussi pas trop trop mal mais
avec j'ai l'impression un petit peu
moins de détails un peu moins de piquer
là-dessus un peu de mode portrait pour
venir finir avec du côté de chez Samsung
cette belle profondeur et se flou qui
est très très beau qui est très
progressif et qui marche bien sur
l'iPhone c'est également la même chose
c'est très très chouette et c'est pas du
tout la même philosophie du côté de chez
Xiaomi ici et fin de la balade on vient
regarder des escaliers comme ça ça
marche bien c'est beau du côté et de
l'autre il y a un rendu qui est très
légèrement différent mais je trouve que
globalement les 360 vraiment bien alors
globalement qu'est-ce qu'il faut venir
retenir ici on a trois smartphones trois
excellent smartphone soyons clairs très
bon photophone mais c'est vrai qu'il y
en a qui sera un peu moins linéaire un
peu moins bon partout ça va être le
Xiaomi 13 pro pourtant il est bon son
mode portrait sympa il est typé il est
différent des autres pour le coup ça
marche bien il y a quelques photos je
vais trouver un peu moins bon un peu
moins de piquer un petit peu moins de
détails notamment au niveau de la photo
de nuit donc il sera un peu en dessous
c'est une très très belle progression
que nous propose Xiaomi ici je vous l'ai
montré sur ma vidéo de test en plus de
ça il y a une vraie très belle
stabilisation lorsque vous venez filmer
avec c'est un excellent photophone trop
peu emmener vraiment partout et ça
montre la progression des Xiaomi ils
vont beaucoup plus loin mais il se
battent face à deux mastodontes deux
marques qui sur maîtrisent leur
téléphone avec d'un côté et bien l'un
des téléphones qui pour l'instant et le
plus beau des plus beaux que j'ai vu en
ce début d'année c'est le Samsung Galaxy
S23 ultra je trouve que l'iPhone 14 pro
Max a vraiment pas rougir parce que même
si des fois je les ai préféré ce que
nous propose Samsung on l'a vu sur la
colorimétrie au niveau de la première
photo dans l'institut c'est beaucoup
plus joli ce que nous propose ici c'est
beaucoup plus juste par contre ce que
l'iPhone ne propose des photos des fois
qu'un peu plus de matière il y a un côté
qu'on a envie de toucher qui est plus
granuleux je vais préférer ici mon
galaxy S23 ultra pour tout ce qui va
être macro on a plus de matière
regarde on analyse ensemble voilà mon
retour dites-moi vous d'ailleurs dans
tout ce qu'on a vu ici qu'est-ce qui
vous a davantage surpris qu'est-ce qui
vous a plu est-ce qu'il y a un truc qui
a été rédhibitoire c'est un truc qui est
plus important est-ce que c'est la photo
de nuit est-ce que c'est le mode
portrait est-ce que c'est le grand angle
ultra grand temps parce que la macro est
un sujet important pour vous marquez moi
ça j'ai très très curieux parce que pour
moi le mode portrait c'est un truc qu'on
va pas trop utiliser et je pourtant je
vois des gens qui l'adorent et qui
l'utilisent bon moi je suis pas
extrêmement convaincu pareil la macro ça
reste un peu gadget mais quand on arrive
à faire des trucs très très cool au
niveau de la macro avec un Galaxy S23
ultra on se dit pourquoi pas si vous
aimez de la photo de nature si vous
voulez aller chercher plus loin et bien
peut-être que c'est le smartphone qui se
vers lequel il faut aller tout en
sachant que et là où il écrase tout le
monde le Galaxy S23 ultra c'est grâce à
son double téléobjectif notamment avec
le X 10 optique et bien on peut aller
très loin très net et il est extrêmement
polyvalent voilà dites-moi ce que vous
en pensez en bas dans les commentaires
et puis s'il y a un de ces trois
smartphones vous intéresse je vous mets
bien évidemment tous les liens en bas
dans la description je t'embrasse prenez
soin de vous et on se voit très bientôt
très très bientôt pour continuer à
parler tech et ça c'est chouette
j'embrasse prenez soin de vous mettre
Ciao
[Musique]